[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday july 27th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
if you have an electric vehicle in the
u.s and you charge it at home you're
probably used to that process taking
several hours
but if you go to a supercharger your
car's battery could be full in just 30
minutes
the problem is that there aren't many
superchargers in the us
the company with the biggest network of
these ultra fast chargers is tesla
but the plugs only work on tesla cars
that could be changing though
the federal government and a lot of
states are making a big push to expand
the charging network for evs on u.s
roads and highways and now regulatory
filings have made it clear that tesla
won some of that public funding which
will mean expanding access to its own
chargers joining us to discuss this is
our energy reporter jennifer hiller hi
jennifer thanks for being here thanks
for having me so before we talk about
tesla's moves can you start us off by
explaining exactly what the u.s
government is trying to do with ev
chargers and why
sure in the infrastructure bill that was
passed by congress last fall there's
billions of dollars in funding for
public ev chargers so there's about 7.5
billion that is potentially on the table
that can go towards helping build out a
public charging infrastructure and
essentially
it is a way for people who have evs to
be able to get power when they are out
and about on road trips and driving and
don't have maybe their home garage or
their condo or apartment building or
office building accessible which might
have
you know a place to plug in over a
period of hours so some of the main
focus is on fast chargers as a way to
build out kind of like the highway
network
sort of like how we have gas stations at
reliable distances all throughout the us
where you know that you can if you're
making a road trip you can pull over and
stop and get
fuel and this kind of fuel would just be
electricity instead of gasoline
so we know from regulatory filings that
tesla is bidding for a portion of the
federal and state funding that's going
to build out the charging network do we
know how it plans to use that money if
it's granted it we don't have tons of
details we can look in their grant
filings and kind of get some hints of
what these might look like the tesla
network is really popular with tesla
drivers it sort of can guide them along
their road trips when they are traveling
and you know it just tells them where to
go charge next and makes the process
really easy and they have about 14 or
1500 sites across the country and they
tend to have several chargers for people
to plug into at each site so they have
like nearly 15 000 chargers at this
point for tesla users only they have
sort of their proprietary
connector and so the issue across the
country is that as the eb market grows
and more people kind of make that switch
to evs that you're going to need to have
a lot more public charging out there
why would tesla want to make the switch
to being a public charging network when
it already has capability to provide
charging for its own users
right that's a great question i think
there's just so much public money on the
table right now
that can help tesla build out its
network even more and so
tesla taking public money to add more
charging stations and more chargers
doesn't mean that it will just turn the
switch and one day all the tesla
locations would be open to drivers of
any kind of ev but it would mean that
those locations where they do take
public money
they would have to allow access to other
kinds of drivers
has tesla commented on its plans
no they have been pretty quiet about how
the details of this would work but they
have said for more than a year now that
they intend to open the network in some
way so what we don't know is exactly
what their time frame is and kind of
what that would look like how much of
the network are they going to open
what about in terms of cost for users do
we know how somebody with a different
kind of ev might be charged for using a
tesla charger in the future yeah there's
no reason to think that everybody would
necessarily pay the same rate
tesla could use discounts for its own
drivers and maybe charge other users a
higher rate
there is kind of a history of this
already within the ev charging industry
where you might have loyalty programs or
membership programs or things like that
so if you pull up to a certain brand of
ev station if you're a member you're
paying a slightly lower rate per
kilowatt hour than somebody who doesn't
have that membership or is not a member
of that loyalty program so that kind of
different tiered pricing exists already
and there's nothing really to indicate
that they would be prohibited from
charging people different rates
i want to take a step back to talk about
how we got into this situation in the us
in the first place because you know we
don't have a system where if you go to a
gas station for instance it's a toyota
gas station or a ford gas station
anybody can use it so why is the
situation with chargers kind of ended up
as this piecemeal situation
it is kind of an odd thing and i think
it's just a sign of an early and young
industry tesla really went out there
with its own proprietary network because
it had to go create a network it did not
exist anywhere else so there was no real
reason for them to like
throw open the gates
so to speak at that point
so what do analysts and observers think
might happen if tesla does throw open
the gates i mean do you think it'll
change demand for other evs
you know that i think is something that
remains to be seen people who keep a
close eye on the ev market in the eb
charging market just say that the need
for public chargers is so immense that
the more chargers the merrier
essentially they want to see anybody
adding these chargers that can possibly
add them
and if they are open to all vehicles and
if it helps kind of build that public
network out
the attitude of ev advocates and
analysts is just the infrastructure
needs are so great that everybody needs
to be building these but you know it's a
tricky industry because
you're putting the infrastructure in
ahead of the market so if they build it
or if we build it they will come as kind
of the the hope they seem to be working
on that yeah that is kind of what people
are assuming is that if you put this
infrastructure in it will make people
feel comfortable enough to buy evs and
we are seeing a lot of you know ev
uptake is increasing and you know they
do seem to be popular there is a lot of
demand for them
all right that's our reporter jennifer
hiller thanks so much for joining us
jennifer thank you
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing
if you want more tech stories check out
our website
wsj.com and if you like our show please
rate and review it you can do that
wherever you get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you